lo más reciente lo más urgente es que
cristina fernández después de muchas
horas muchas muchas horas más de un día
de silencio publicó una carta pública
abierta en su sitio web en su blog en la
que dice algunas cosas muy fuertes dice
que en numerosas reuniones con el
presidente señale que creía que se
estaba llevando a cabo una política de
ajuste fiscal equivocada que estaba
impactando negativamente en la actividad
económica y de dice también en la carta
que ya insistía en que eso llevaría a
perder en las elecciones también dice
que una vez que se perdió cree que los
funcionarios deberían haber puesto la
renuncia a esa disposición y le pide al
presidente que relanza su gobierno y
algo muy importante para que entienda el
público en otros países que no son
argentina cristina fernández de kirchner
le recuerda en la carta que fue ella la
que lo postuló como presidente y ella
como vice de cara a las elecciones de
2019 porque ella a pesar de tener muchos
votos de contar con muchos votos de la
población no tenía votos suficientes
para llegar a ganar esa elección en 2019
de entonces se conformó esta coalición
peronista que hoy está en crisis con
alberto fernández como presidenta y ella
como vice ella y de modificaciones en el
curso del gobierno modificaciones
específicamente en lo económico que haya
más ayuda ayuda social que haya más
gasto público alberto fernández con
suministro de economía por ahora no
están presentando un presupuesto en ese
sentido hay que ver si lo van a cambiar
no está claro todavía qué va a suceder
si fernández va a aceptar o no va a
aceptar estas renuncias presentadas de
forma según el gobierno informal que nos
fueron presentadas dicen en forma formal
sino mediática pero todavía hay que ver
dónde está la pelota alberto fernández
permanentemente intenta frenar la pelota
como escuchábamos antes y usamos una
metáfora futbolística y de repente todo
empieza a moverse nuevamente y todavía
no sabemos cómo termina este partido en
argentina natalio pues nos parece que
esta atención vaya a relajarse pronto
estaremos muy pendientes de lo que
ocurre